working with the Taylor twins in three
words spontaneous joyful and very loving
sometimes nothing hi everyone I'm here
with Lincoln and gunner Taylor and they
play baby Jack I'm going to calls the
heart they are such a joy to get to play
with every day as you can see a typical
day on set with the babies is joyful its
cuddly there's lots to smile about
occasionally there are a few tears we've
had to wake the babies up from nap time
a couple times that's not their
preference but for the most part it's
really really nice when we started
season six it felt like Lincoln started
off much more outgoing and then Gunnar
became more outgoing one by the end of
the season so their personalities
they'll kind of flip flopped a bit that
they are very focused and involved
zyne so often times up looking at the
other characters that I'm looking at
during the scene and they stay really
involved they're making expressions
similar to the ones that I'm making and
anyway they keep my hands full I don't
know how the real moment does but there
have been some super cute funny moments
on set one of the babies just reached up
and stuck his whole fist in my mouth at
one point so that was pretty cute there
was pretty smile to our faces huh we're
very lucky to have you
movement is a lot of movement and maybe
we'll get to see some first steps and
some first words a lot of firsts with
the babies as we all know we've had some
some sad moments over the years and one
calls the heart and I have to say these
babies have brought so much joy to our
entire cast and crew everyone lights up
when they come on set
and I think it's pretty funny to see
some of our more bacon burly crew
members talking and googoo gaga
Baby Talk the babies just make
everyone's hearts melt there they're the
best thank you so much for watching we
can't wait to share season seven with
you right we'll see you soon
[Music]